[Música]
la República popular china es un país
que aspira rivalizar con los mismísimos
Estados Unidos un país que durante las
últimas décadas ha experimentado un
crecimiento Nacho vidaliano y que se ha
convertido Ni más ni menos que en la
gran fábrica del mundo pero no solo
hablamos de economía ahora china también
quiere su papel geopolítico pensando así
quién conocía a los anteriores
presidentes de China por ejemplo os
suena huintao seguramente no sin embargo
es omnipresente en todos los medios de
comunicación del planeta No importa que
estemos hablando de Ucrania de Irán de
Venezuela de Brasil o del Pacífico sur
este país No para de protagonizar
grandes titulares que casi siempre
tienen un denominador común la ambición
de extender lo antes posible su
influencia por todo el mundo son muchos
los planes que Pekín ha trazado para
conseguir este objetivo pero hasta ahora
prácticamente todos ellos han tenido
siempre un ingrediente principal
inversión inversión y más inversión pero
todo eso ya lo sabéis lo importante
viene ahora todo esto
a cambiar y diréis por qué Pues
básicamente porque la economía china no
atraviesa su mejor momento tiene una
burbuja inmobiliaria a puntito de
estallar las empresas extranjeras cada
vez desconfían más de este país y el
crecimiento de su pib Digamos que ya no
es lo que era cierto es verdad que este
año están remontando Pero esto se debe
en parte a la reapertura del país tras
su política de covid cero sin embargo en
el vídeo de hoy vamos a centrarnos en un
aspecto muy concreto de la política
china recordáis la nueva ruta de la seda
el proyecto belt and Roses se trata de
uno de los proyectos de infraestructura
más ambiciosos de la historia y además
es la gran apuesta de Pink se anunció a
bombo y platillo en el año 2013 es decir
hace ya 10 años y la pregunta es está
funcionando de verdad china puede
recuperar todos esos miles de millones
de dólares que ha invertido en rescatar
tantos países o hablamos del inicio de
un Monumental fracaso hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Aplausos]
[Música]
si sois veteranos seguidores de
visualpolitik ya conocéis de sobra lo
que es la nueva ruta de la seda para
quien no lo conozca os haga un resumen
Durante los últimos años Pekín ha
invertido o planeado invertir una
auténtica fortuna en construir todo tipo
de infraestructuras puertos carreteras y
puentes por todo el planeta tierra El
objetivo extender sus tentáculos por el
resto del mundo y convertirse en el
epicentro de la economía mundial casi
nada Hablamos de un catálogo de
proyectos entre los que se encuentran
obras faraónicas como esta aquí están
apruebo una mejora ferroviaria por valor
de 6.800 millones de dólares el proyecto
forma parte del multimillonario acuerdo
del corredor económico china Pakistán
China tiene previsto destinar 60.000
millones de dólares a proyectos de
infraestructuras en Pakistán china
estudia un tren bala de 7.000 kilómetros
para conectar Pekín y Moscú Y por
supuesto este proyecto viene acompañado
de toda la narrativa nacionalista que
cabría esperar de un líder como
chiquitin la vuelta al esplendor del
imperio chino y es que veréis entre el
año 130 antes de Cristo y 1450 después
de Cristo la ruta de la seda era una de
las rutas comerciales más importantes de
todo el mundo promovió la expansión del
Imperio Romano y el bizantino el Imperio
persas sanidad el Imperio kusan Y por
supuesto la dinastía Tang de la propia
china sin embargo toda gran historia
tiene un gran final
[Música]
hacía a principios del siglo 15 el
Imperio otomano boicoteó el comercio con
occidente lo que provocó el cierre de
buena parte de todas las arterias
comerciales que formaban la histórica
ruta de la seda esa circunstancia obligó
a las emergentes potencias europeas a
buscar nuevos caminos para llegar hasta
Asia recordáis que por ejemplo Cristóbal
Colón llegó a las Américas buscando una
nueva ruta hacia las indias Pues ahora
ya sabéis el porqué
eso sí cuando Europa descubrió América
Todo cambió de repente el Atlántico se
puso de moda y la ruta de la seda perdió
toda su importancia sin embargo en 2013
decidió sacarla de sus cenizas el
gigante chino regresaba a la escena
mundial tras siglos de letargo Pero cuál
era el plan de sillín exactamente Pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
de la discreción al gigantismo
[Música]
la nueva ruta de la seda se ha
posicionado como la punta de lanza del
nuevo expansionismo chino sin embargo el
origen de esta idea Fue totalmente
diferente este proyecto nació de una
forma muy acotada como una vía para
impulsar el comercio interasiático
fijaos 7 de septiembre de 2013 china
propone la recuperación de la ruta de la
seda en una visita Asia central con el
fin de reforzar Los lazos económicos y
la cooperación y ampliar el espacio de
desarrollo de los países de urasia
podemos aplicar un nuevo modelo al crear
el corredor económico de la ruta de la
seda sillín en principio el plan era
simplemente una ruta para unir
kazajistán con Indonesia pasando por
China y por eso el plan tenía dos partes
una ruta terrestre y una ruta marítima a
la que llamamos el Collar de perlas un
proyecto que en principio estaba pensado
únicamente para el comercio sin embargo
el interés que automáticamente despertó
en muchos países hizo que Pekín se diera
cuenta del enorme potencial político que
tenía esta apuesta el plan parecía
sencillo de sacar adelante además daba
trabajo empresas chinas y reforzaba el
comercio con este país pero no sólo eso
para un montón de países este proyecto
era todo una oportunidad para conseguir
dinero de China vamos que enseguida se
formó toda una cola de gobiernos
dispuestos a poner la alfombra roja al
capital chino y por eso en 2017 escaló
La Apuesta de repente ya no era algo
limitado Asia sino a todo el mundo y así
es como abrió seis grandes corredores y
lo describió como el proyecto del siglo
desde entonces los proyectos se ha
multiplicado para construir sobre todo
infraestructuras de transporte energía y
telecomunicaciones aunque también se
contemplan hospitales centros educativos
y otros proyectos de corte más social en
todos los casos china financia las obras
a cambio de que la construcción por
regla general y en ocasiones también la
gestión recaiga en las propias empresas
chinas y los países receptores sean
digamos más receptivos con la política
exterior del gigante asiático por
ejemplo en lo que respecta a los choques
con Taiwán o Estados Unidos
queréis un ejemplo pues os doy un
ejemplo energía china ha financiado o
está financiando 44 proyectos para
construir centrales de Carbón pero es
que también están construyendo miles de
kilómetros de carreteras y de
ferrocarriles y la pregunta es qué
países necesitan estas inversiones
quienes necesitan fuentes de energía
convencionales o infraestructuras Pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
Dime con quién andas y te diré quién
eres
[Música]
aquí Viene un dato clave para Pekín casi
la mitad de los países que forman parte
de esta iniciativa son países de
ingresos bajos es decir que gran parte
de las economías en vías de desarrollo
están subidas en este barco por ejemplo
43 países del África subsahariana ya se
han sumado este proyecto Y por qué esto
es tan importante Pues porque hablamos
de países y sobre todo de gobiernos con
relativamente pocos recursos que pueden
tener muy difícil Acceder al capital
para financiar grandes proyectos y justo
Aquí es donde entra lo que aquí en
visualpolitik llamamos la diplomacia
Sugar Daddy y occidente natural del
dinero no te preocupes papi sigue un pin
se encarga de todo y que pide a cambio
tu lealtad tanto política como económica
Esta es básicamente la idea os ayudamos
a financiar vuestro desarrollo y a
cambio para todos vosotros Pekín se
convertirá en la gran referencia
política del mundo por ejemplo que la
ONU Busca condenar a China por la toma
de Hong Kong o la persecución de los
suigures de lo que ya hemos hablado
ampliamente aquí en visualpolitik no hay
problema papis y pin tiene Sugar babies
por todas partes no me creéis pues
atentos
fijaos en 2020 cuando china sacó la ley
de seguridad nacional en Hong Kong de
los 53 países que firmaron una
declaración de apoyo a China en el
consejo de derechos humanos de la ONU 25
eran africanos y otros tres grandes
países Nigeria Sudáfrica y Kenia aunque
no la secundaron tampoco se sumaron a
las críticas contra Pekín es lo que
muchos han venido a denominar como la
estrategia de la trampa de la deuda esto
es china promueve que estos países se
endeuden hasta el cuello para que así se
conviertan en Estados completamente
dependientes prácticamente vasallos sea
como sea así es como luce actualmente el
mapa de la nueva ruta de la seda china
ya cuenta con la adhesión de países que
representan más de un tercio de toda la
economía mundial
Aunque eso sí un apunte importante
últimamente la colaboración de muchos de
los países europeos está en peligro Y
diréis por qué pues en ocnius ya os
hemos hablado recientemente de la crisis
política que china ha desatado por su
persecución contra lituania para estar
al tanto no olvidéis suscribiros a
nuestra nueva newsletter gratuita que se
llama not news.com os dejo el enlace en
los comentarios pero no nos desviamos
sigamos con el tema de hoy
hasta aquí todo pintaba muy bien china
apartado sacar adelante inversiones
conjuntas con cerca de 140 países 150
países que ahora tienen mucha más
relación y mucha más dependencia de
Pekín y atentos porque esto es quizás el
detalle más importante y más revelador
de toda esta historia los derechos
civiles veréis según el ranking de
libertades políticas y civiles de la
freedom House los países con menor
puntuación es decir los menos
democráticos son los más propensos
asociarse con china dicho de otra forma
Pekín quiere formar un bloque conformado
por países que tienen un patrón común
son relativamente pobres con pocas
libertades civiles y democracias débiles
o inexistentes por supuesto aquí están
embarcadas la inmensa mayor parte de las
dictaduras del mundo para que os hagáis
una idea en el mundo existen 57 países
que están considerados como autoritarios
y no libres es decir básicamente
dictaduras bastante autoritarias donde
cosas como la libertad de expresión o la
libertad de prensa evidentemente no
están toleradas Pues bien de esos 57
países 52 participan activamente en el
Macro proyecto de Jean Pink pensando así
cuanto menos democrático es un país más
fácil es conseguir su lealtad
incondicional basta con convencer a las
élites gobernantes y cubrirles de dinero
y proyectos de vanidad para ganarse su
lealtad incondicional Esta es la clave
de la diplomacia Sugar Daddy y ya sé lo
que estaréis pensando todo esto suena
malvado y maquiavélico pero funciona
estamos ante el plan definitivo de
dominación mundial O tal vez no pues
bien han pasado casi 8 años desde que
china decidiera convertirse en el Sugar
Daddy de la política internacional
suficiente tiempo como para ver ya
algunos resultados vamos a verlos
[Música]
los primeros palos en la rueda
si incluimos a la propia china más de la
mitad del mundo está embarcada de una
forma u otra en el proyecto One Road en
este sentido podemos decir que la
apuesta de Pekín ha dado resultado casi
todos los países en vías de desarrollo
tienen hoy lazos mucho más estrechos con
Pekín el problema El problema es que no
todos estos países tienen sus finanzas
en orden
lo que se ha venido a conocer como la
trampa de la deuda Ahora corre el riesgo
de convertirse en una especie de
Boomerang para Pekín la política de
crecer crecer y crecer a cualquier
precio está empezando a dejar de
funcionar tanto dentro como fuera de
China
ya os lo hemos dicho la economía china
no está atravesando su mejor momento
atentos los estímulos económicos en
China pueden empeorar las distorsiones
las medidas de estímulo en
infraestructuras podrían Elevar el
crecimiento en el Horizonte proyectado
pero podrían Conducir a una mayor
acumulación de desequilibrios y mala
asignación de capital y por lo tanto
provocar un crecimiento más débil en el
medio plazo estudio de la acb sobre la
economía china a partir del año 2016 las
autoridades chinas empezaron a hacer
todo lo posible para reducir el exceso
de deuda que tenían sobre todo las
empresas públicas sin embargo la cosa no
funcionó y en el año 2019 el panorama se
empezó a complicar en noviembre de 2020
una serie de impagos de empresas
estatales de alto perfil envió ondas de
choque al sistema financiero a través
del el mercado de bonos corporativos de
china en febrero de 2021 el Banco
Popular de China retiró la liquidez
interbancaria lo que provocó Un aumento
significativo de los tipos de interés
Esto es algo que no se suele contar pero
tanto los gobiernos regionales y los
municipales como las propias empresas
públicas de China son completamente
adictos a la deuda están apalancados
hasta el cuello y de hecho el volumen de
deuda que ya acumula la economía china
es gigantesco
será la fábrica del mundo y tiene un
sector privado relativamente competitivo
Y eso tiene muchas ventajas Pero mis
queridos amigos de visualpolitik Lo
cierto es que las finanzas públicas en
China están cada vez en peor forma y ojo
porque aunque la deuda del gobierno
nacional sea Aparentemente baja en las
estadísticas oficiales el problema está
camuflado en los balances de las
empresas públicas y eso es algo que cada
vez genera más preocupación pero no solo
eso también está provocando que ya no
baste con tirar de deuda y gastar más y
más para poder cumplir con esos
objetivos de crecimiento económico
anuales que se fija al gobierno en parte
y precisamente por eso el crecimiento de
China se está ralentizando en los
últimos años pero no sólo eso desde el
año 2018 el impago de bonos corporativos
ha crecido exponencialmente
el principal problema de un rápido
aumento de la carga de la deuda
corporativa Incluso si son las empresas
públicas las que se endeudan es que
deben utilizarse cantidades
significativas de crédito nuevo para
atender el servicio de la deuda más
antigua por lo que cada Joan de crédito
nuevo ya no genera la misma actividad
económica que en el pasado para que os
hagáis una idea el problema es tan
gigantesco que los intereses que tienen
que pagar la deuda emitida en China ya
superan ampliamente el crecimiento
económico del país y claro si la
economía crece menos Entonces el peso de
la deuda Se incrementa lo que a su vez
castiga el crecimiento y vuelta a
empezar y ya sé lo que os estaréis
preguntando muchos a ver Fonseca pero
todo esto qué demonios tiene que ver con
la ruta de la seda es que acaso hemos
perdido la cabeza aquí en visualpolitik
y hemos cambiado de repente de tema pues
evidentemente no
El problema es que en la última década
china ha sostenido su crecimiento
económico a base de endeudarse más más y
más es decir han crecido a base de sacar
adelante enormes Macro proyectos que han
creado todo una burbuja de inversión en
el país que ahora no está generando los
beneficios esperados todo lo contrario
ahora es el momento en el que hay que
empezar a pagar la fiesta y sabéis que
eso es algo muy parecido a lo que ya
está ocurriendo en muchos de los países
que tan alegremente se sumaron a la
nueva ruta de la seda prestad mucha pero
que muchísima atención
[Música]
cría cuervos y te sacarán los ojos
con la nueva ruta de la seda o como se
conoce formalmente en plan One Road en
marcha el dinero comenzó a fluir a lo
grande china envió un enorme océano de
dólares ahí fuera el problema El
problema es que cuando se trata de
recuperar esas deudas solo está llegando
un riachuelo En otras palabras que
muchos de los países que recibieron el
dinero chino ahora no pueden cumplir con
los pagos de la deuda que habían
acordado lo que está obligando al
gobierno chino a rescatarlos sí habéis
oído bien a rescatarlos y ojo porque la
broma Ya está empezando a salir
demasiado cara según un reciente estudio
elaborado por investigadores de eidata
el Banco Mundial la escuela Kennedy de
Harvard y el Instituto kiel para la
economía mundial china ha tenido que
rescatar casi 100.000 millones de
dólares en deudas tan solo entre los
años 2019 y 2021 en total hablamos ya de
200.000 millones de dólares en rescates
a países como Angola Pakistán Venezuela
shirlanca o Sudán pero esperad un
momento porque esto no es lo peor de
todo todos estos préstamos iban para
construir infraestructura verdad pero en
países tan corruptos ese dinero
desaparece en cosas como sobornos sobre
costes vamos que muchos de estos
proyectos de infraestructuras no han
servido para construir nada al menos
nada que funcione Eso sí más de un
dictador si ha hecho de oro con el
dinero de papis y kingpin y no creáis
que hablamos de uno o dos proyectos
atentos el 35% de la cartera de
proyectos de infraestructuras de la
iniciativa de la franja y la ruta se ha
enfrentado a graves problemas de
ejecución como escándalos de corrupción
violaciones laborales riesgos
medioambientales y protestas públicas
ahora bien quiero decir todo esto que la
nueva ruta de la seda pasará a ser
historia pues Pita mal pero por ahora lo
único que podemos decir es que hace
aguas claro que también es cierto que
china podría hacer de tripas corazón
[Música]
no hay mal que por bien no venga
por primera vez desde que arrancará el
siglo XXI china se está enfrentando una
fuerte desaceleración económica La
burbuja de inversiones que ha creado
dentro y fuera de sus fronteras podría
estar a puntito de estallar Sin embargo
un momento la conclusión de la
investigación que hemos mencionado antes
también tiene algo muy inquietante según
este estudio la crisis actual de China
puede ser parte de su maduración
competitiva contra los Estados Unidos
este estudio plantea literalmente lo
siguiente observamos paralelismos
históricos con la época en la que
Estados Unidos inició su ascenso como
potencia financiera mundial
Especialmente los años 30 y tras la
Segunda Guerra Mundial cuando utilizó el
sistema financiero para proporcionar
fondos de rescate a países con grandes
pasivos frente a bancos y exportadores
estadounidenses con el tiempo Estas
actividades de Estados Unidos se
convirtieron en un sistema probado de
gestión global de crisis
[Música]
es que china podría aprender a cómo
lidiar con los problemas con sus
inversiones En estos países y
desarrollar los mecanismos necesarios
para poder gestionarlas y ojo porque
esto podría ser una herramienta muy pero
que muy valiosa para impulsar sus
relaciones económicas y financieras con
todos estos estados claro que también
hay muchas diferencias veréis tras la
Segunda Guerra Mundial la economía de
los Estados Unidos iba viento en popa
ahora no podemos decir lo mismo con la
de China y eso por no recordar que el
régimen de Spin es una durísima
dictadura Y si algo tienen claro los
dictadores es que no se puede fiar de
los otros dictadores por eso al final
todos ellos terminan llevando su dinero
de un modo u otro a los Estados Unidos
sea como sea Lo cierto es que la nueva
ruta de la seda se ha convertido en un
enorme quebradero de cabeza otro más
para Pekín la pregunta ahora es creéis
que china podrá lidiar con todos estos
problemas puede terminar este
macroproyecto convertido en un enorme
boquete presupuestario es este el final
del gran sueño de sglymping podéis
dejarnos vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
Que aquí en visualpolitik sacamos vídeos
nuevos Todas las semanas así que
suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un saludo y hasta
pronto
[Música]